big star and in in France and in Europe
and then you come here and it's like you
had to learn all over again because all
of your comedy now is in a language that
until recently has been pretty foreign
to you yeah what I came here like a year
ago I didn't even speak English like
this yeah I work very hard and now I
think it's okay yeah I don't you know
what's the most difficult thing in
English for French speakers but it's not
the words it's to know where to put the
emphasis in the words mm-hmm and you
guys don't help us like we tell you the
words I one day I said to a friend of
mine he's American I went on vacation he
said what's that and then he said you
mean a vacation yeah
and they don't meet me halfway right
that's a problem right right yeah
they're not going to that's Americans if
we get so self-centered about it no it's
just it's it's just so it's new to me
and comedy you know how the language is
important for for a comedy but there's a
another words are there certain words
now that you're like that you've learned
in English that you think okay this
particularly weird word that American I
just like when you guys make up stuff
like I had some work done in my
apartment in New York and and the the
contractor said we should put French
doors
and I was like what is that because I
swear I've never seen this info and he
said French doors are actually doors you
open like this yeah and then I said so
why would you call them French doors and
I swear he said kiss I guess it's
because when you walk through those
doors you look like a French person a
lot of words I don't know oh there's one
word in English because you guys came up
with words for everything I love that
there's one word when I go shopping that
I love we don't have it impress what's
it the words browsing browsing you know
how many words you I would have to use
in France to send the same message it
would be crazy like I don't really know
if I want to buy or not depends on the
butcher that if I find something I need
to call my wife a tablet here browsing
all right I love that and and there's
things we probably take for granted like
that we think everybody uses but they
don't right now like I like also so for
some reason people tell you Oh for some
reason I couldn't make it and I'm like
what's the difference between saying
that and not saying anything because for
some reason and I'm like oh really for
some reason oh are you okay and this is
the absurdist mob of the language but I
love I love it you know his bunch of you
said bunch of stuff oh yeah that was
yeah I told you this like bunch of stuff
is great it's so vague how many's a
bunch you guys have no idea stuff just
whatever a bunch of stuff
yes and my favorite word in English you
know what is my favorite one it's
toddler a toddler a toddler yeah toddler
is a kid between they don't know I mean
they don't even know you know how big is
that what about a bunch of toddlers I
don't know it's we don't like specifics
in this country nobody have words for
everything like I don't know it's uh
it's interesting
you